TO THE SPECIAL EDITION OF
HANNITY.
SPEAKING AT THE OBAMA FOUNDATION
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA TOOK
THINLY VEILED SWIPE AT PRESIDENT
TRUMP, SAYING AMERICA'S PROGRESS
IS HINDERED BY, QUOTE, HATE,
ANGER, RACISM, AND MOMMY ISSUES.
HUH.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE REASON WE DON'T DO IT IS
BECAUSE WE ARE STILL CONFUSED,
BLIND, SHROUDED WITH HATE,
ANGER, RACISM, MOMMY ISSUES.
>> Judge Jeanine: IN 2014
INTERVIEW WITH FORMER PRESIDENT
BUSH, HANNITY ASKED HIM WHY HE
CON SIS TINTEDLY REFUSED TO
CRITICIZE HIS SUCCESSORS.
LOOK AT HIS RESPONSE.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU MAKE THE
DECISION KOISHGS SIT HERE ALL
DAY AND TRY TO GET YOU TO
COMMENT ON PRESIDENT OBAMA, AND
I'M NOT GOING TO GET ANYWHERE.
>> CORRECT.
>> Sean: I KNOW YOU VERY WELL.
>> YOU DO.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION?
I'M SURE YOU HAVE A LOT TO SAY.
YOU'RE NOT -- WE'VE TALKED
POLITICS BEFORE WE CAME IN HERE,
YOU ARE VERY ENGAGED NO MATTER
IS GOING ON.
>> I'M VERY AWARE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY TO HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT UNDERMINE A CURRENT
PRESIDENT.
IT'S BAD FOR THE PRESIDENCY FOR
THAT MATTER.
>> Judge Jeanine: JOINING ME
WITH REACTION SAY, LEM RADIO
TALK SHOW HOST LARRY AND FORMER
ADVISOR TO PRESIDENT OBAMA
AUSTIN GOOLSBEE.
IT IS SHOCKING THAT A PRESIDENT
WOULD COME OUT AND CRITICIZE A
PRESIDENT THE WAY WE'VE SEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA DO.
SO I AM GOING TO START WITH YOU,
AUSTIN.
THERE IS A BOOK "THE PRESIDENT'S
CLUB" I'M SURE ARE YOU FAMILIAR
WITH.
IT DOCUMENTS THE UNIQUE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PRESIDENTS,
WHERE THE SITTING PRESIDENT WILL
HAVE COMMUNICATIONS WITH FOREIGN
PRESIDENTS.
BECAUSE THEIR EXPERIENCE IS SO
UNIQUE, HAVING SHARED THE OVAL
OFFICE, AND THOSE INCREDIBLE
DECISIONS AND BURDENS THAT THEY
CARRY.
SO THERE IS A RELATIONSHIP THAT
THEY HAVE.
BUT PRESIDENT OBAMA FROM THE
LAST WEEK OR TWO THAT HE, YOU
KNOW, OF THE RACE, HE TOOK EVERY
DAY TO GO OUT AND CAMPAIGN
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
HE DID IT IN THE MID TERMS.
IT'S UNHEARD OF.
IS IT GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY, AS
GEORGE BUSH JUST SAID?
>> WELL, I THINK HE KIND OF
MAKES TWO THINGS.
I THINK FOR SURE, IN, LOOK, IT'S
THANKSGIVING IS TOMORROW.
IN THE SPIRIT OF THANKSGIVING,
LET'S HOPE THAT EVERYONE TONES
DOWN THE KIND OF PERSONAL
RHETORIC AND REFER TO MOMMY
ISSUES, I THINK STUFF LIKE THAT
IS BEYOND BOUNDS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WELL, AND
AUSTIN, WHAT WOULD PEOPLE SAY IF
I REFERRED TO PRESIDENT OBAMA AS
HAVING MOMMY ISSUES.
OR DADDY ISSUES.
>> YEAH, BUT, NOW WAIT, JUDGE,
THE THING IS YOU KNOW THAT THIS
IS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
NOW SAYING SOME OUTRAGEOUS
THINGS.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT, WHAT IS
HE RESPONDING TO?
>> WELL, FOR EXAMPLE, PRESIDENT
TRUMP CALLING PRESIDENT OBAMA
THE MOST IGNORANT PRESIDENT IN
THE HISTORY OF AMERICA.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHEN DID HE DO
THAT?
>> SAYING PRESIDENT OBAMA WASN'T
BORN IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT --
>> HIS OWN FAMILY SAYING
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: COME, ON
JUSTIFIED IN CONTINUING THE
NARRATIVE?
>> NO, HE'S NOT JUSTIFIED, I'M
NOT, I'M NOT SAYING HE'S
JUSTIFIED.
HE SHOULDN'T DO THAT.
I RESPECTED GEORGE BUSH'S
APPROACH.
>> Judge Jeanine: WE ALL DO.
>> THAT'S THE APPROACH PRESIDENT
OBAMA SHOULD TAKE.
VICE PRESIDENT CHENEY WAS MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE AND NEGATIVE
ABOUT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE ENTIRE TIME.
I RESPECTED GEORGE BUSH'S
APPROACH.
>> Judge Jeanine: I'LL GO TO
YOU, LET ME GO TO YOU, LARRY,
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PRESIDENT'S, NOT VICE
PRESIDENTS.
AND OBAMA UNDID THE SIGNATURE
ACHIEVEMENT OF GEORGE W. BUSH,
THAT WAS THE WAR IN IRAQ WHEN
GEORGE BUSH LEFT OFFICE HE
ASSUMED THERE WAS GOING TO BE A
STAY BEHIND HORSE OF BETWEEN
5,000 AND 10,000 TROOPS TROOPS.
PREDICTED WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
THERE WAS A VACUUM.
OBAMA PULLED OUT EVERY SINGLE
TROOP.
GEORGE W. BUSH DIDN'T SAY ONE
WORD AS THINGS GOT WORSE IN
IRAQ.
AS HE PREDICTED.
IT IS TRUE THAT VICE PRESIDENT
DICK CHENEY SAID SOMETHING BUT
GEORGE W. BUSH DIDN'T SAY A
WORD.
RONALD REAGAN RETIRES, GOES SIMI
VALLEY, DUS SAINT A WORD.
GEORGE HERBERT WALKER BUSH, DUS
SAINT A WORD.
GEORGE BUSH GOES TO TEXAS,
DOESN'T SAY A WORD.
CLINTON, BROVM, NEVER STOP
TALKING -- BARACK OBAMA, NEVER
STOP TALKING.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND HE MAY
HAVE A POINT, IT SEEMS TO BE THE
DEMOCRATS COMING OUT.
AND I HAVE TO SAY -- GO AHEAD.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK THAT THAT
IS QUITE ACCURATE.
THE ONLY THING I'LL SAY --
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT WASN'T
ACCURATE?
>> DONALD TRUMP -- WELL, IN THE
SENSE THAT BARACK OBAMA DID NOT
MENTION.
TRUMP BY NAME.
NOUR, IF PRESIDENT TRUMP, NOBODY
IN THE COUNTRY --
>> YOU KNEW WHO HE WAS TALKING
ABOUT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TAKE A LESSON
IN APPROPRIATENESS, NOT TO
INSULT PEOPLE, FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP?
HE COMPARED HIS ENTIRE CAMPAIGN
WAS BUILT ON PERSONAL INSULTS OF
HIS OPPONENT AND SAYING ABOUT,
SPEAKING ABOUT THE EXTREME
STUPIDITY OF EVERYONE.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT THAT'S NOT
THE ISSUE WE'RE TALK ABOUT.
>> WHAT IS THE ISSUE?
>> Judge Jeanine: WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A PRESIDENT WHO COMES OUT
DURING MID TERMS AND DURING THE
END OF HIS OFFICE TO CONTINUALLY
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> CAMPAIGNING IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: BUT NOW HE'S
NOT CAMPAIGNING, IT'S AFTER THE
MID TERMS, AUSTIN.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE LAST WORD,
LARRY ELDER.
>> OKAY, AUSTIN, IF IT MAKES YOU
HAPPIER, WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
RETIRES IN JANUARY OF 2025 WITH
HIS 50 MILLION TWITTER
FOLLOWERS, HE WILL PROBABLY HAVE
A THING OR TWO TO SAY ABOUT HIS